Hello, you are watching the Ukrainian channel. We
continue to understand how
Russia is organized, taking as a basis the concept of
mechanisms for the protection of the psyche, in this video
we will show you how the Russian
subconscious works and why all Russians should
take a course of psychotherapy. If you
liked this video, write a comment
below so that this video gets into the trends  And
if you also want an English-language version,
then Olov and Ukrainian in English, the
historical states of Russia,
in psychology there is a concept of psychological protection mechanisms,
this is what helps a
person adapt to the environment and
reduce the level of stress and traumatic
experiences, for example, a person can
push out unpleasant thoughts from the subconscious
or attribute his experiences  and
desire to others, I express myself in a very
different way, with slyness. Here we are, I
can’t even speak Ukrainian. I have put
her bones
in a different way. Perhaps, on the example of Russia’s attack on
Ukraine, we can see how the people of the country resort to defensive mechanisms,
and with them, to the manipulation of meanings.
Russia is not an aggressor
just daily commits crimes against
humanity with the hands of its military and
distorts the information space in its
favor. For years, it has been calling black and
white, war, the desire for peace, and
whether its population is a medicine for you, a people, or
small people on whom
nothing depends. In this material, we clearly
show that big statements  Russian
figures about greatness and peacemaking are
manifestations of unconscious mechanisms of the collective
psyche, and the Russian cliché with which they
try to justify the attack on
sovereign countries, in particular Ukraine, is not only a
lie, but also an irrefutable proof that the
entire people of the aggressor country
need psychotherapy,
that Ukraine was going to attack the Russian Federation, this
statement is its example  Projections are a phenomenon when a
person unconsciously prescribes their desires,
actions and needs to other people.
characteristic obsessive
ideas
that the coronavirus is said to be China
And you have the opposite, how many
can these be far-fetched feelings that a person is being
persecuted, they want to kill everyone around them are
traitors, etc., which we see in the case
of Russia, Russians believe that the whole world
is hostile to them  and wishes them evil. And all their
actions are not their responsibility. Ukraine was being
prepared for an attack on Russia. I am
absolutely sure of this. Why
is America coming here? Ukraine forced Russia to
attack. We had no choice.
also pushes her to
meet her expectations and wishes
. The aggressor state cannot accept that
Ukraine is not only independent but also ready to
defend its independence. Russia itself
provoked and started the war, but it is more
comfortable for her to live with the idea that
Ukraine is the aggressor.
Shansov will do this to Russia, the war
acquires a special meaning and almost
sacred significance for  is thinking
about the special operation, I think that it is evil,
but inevitable, otherwise, well,
there were probably no
other options.
Russia brings peace to the people of Ukraine.
This is not only a hint of an unknown Orwellian
phrase, war is peace, but also an example of
reactive formation. This is a mechanism that
replaces unacceptable
things with the opposite, often exaggerated
for example, excessive love can be a
manifestation of hatred, and pity can be a manifestation of
indifference to the cruelty and indifference of thousands of lives.
This is true. It is
bitter.  we will help you, this is the
case when the Hugs are strong but
not really benevolent. And this is another
example of how Russia, by changing the facts,
tries to give meaning to its actions and
play the reality.
We hope that the fascist
regime in Ukraine will destroy it. We
hope that the genocide will end on a national
basis and by conviction, and
that there will be peace in Ukraine. Russia will not
bomb cities. This is an example of denial, a
mechanism for rejecting thoughts, desires, needs
or realities that are unacceptable on a conscious level. A
person behaves as if they are
problems.  there is no such mechanism, which is often
characteristic of children, thanks to it they
cope with information about
troubles, for example, with disasters,
if you hide under a blanket, then the terrible
reality seems to cease to exist, the
Russian armed forces do not bomb cities,
and this is well known, well, in
fact, Russia does not bomb, it gets rid of it
people who seized
power, this mechanism prevents them from realizing and
burning away the tragedy in Russia, this is
how the people pretend that there is no great war, because
the Ukrainians bomb themselves, and the
Russian army helps to establish peace,
and the influence of sanctions does not affect
their lives in any way, the radio is strong, we will
win nothing for us  Oh, don’t worry,
Russia is a great country.
This is a manifestation of the idealization of a person’s overestimation of
his or someone else’s qualities, for example, when a
child believes that his parents can do
everything for him, even turn on the rain, and
Russia idealizes its imperial past and the
constant expansion of its borders due to the
conquest of the territory of sovereign countries. This
helps it to maintain  the myth of my
alleged self-sufficiency, I am a Russian, I
am not afraid of anything, we will defeat everyone, but
illusions also prevent Russia from soberly
accepting the reality of its attack on Dubai,
well, now, we will raise a little bit of taxes,
well, there is something else that is terrible, but without
playing around, we will visit sister in
Russia, it started only with  Gaza will
end completely, we will break
diplomatic relations with you. You
hear us. You consider our country a
territory.
when she isn't  she can get what she wants,
she does not recognize her own shortcomings, therefore she
finds reasons to find another person
or to act on her and other phenomena from Ukraine are
fighting in a completely - technical
military point of view, we are fighting with NATO, on the
example of Russia, we see that they devalue
not only the power of the Ukrainian rear army,
but also  their losses of equipment and manpower
[music]
so Russians seem to live in an information
looking-glass, unable to critically assess
their state of affairs and prospects
TV Why should I do more
in Ukraine Nazis and drug addicts have seized
power, this is a manifestation of rationalization or
defensive motivation that occurs when a
person who understands the inaccessibility  the desirable
begins to reduce its value or when
something bad happens, she
tries to prove to herself and others that it is
not so bad and that there is some benefit in this,
so people begin to normalize
anything, even war crimes, as
we can see on the example of Russia
by the Nazis of
Bandera on which  The USA of their matches companions
made a bet budet n  еизбежным
Украина
Where have you been all these 8 years? This is not just a
fake about the fact that the armed forces of Ukraine have
allegedly been shelling their eastern Ukraine since 2014.
This is moralization, a close
relative of rationalization.
or what did you do all these 8 years Tom How do you
ask the citizens of Ukraine that 8 years
ago no one of you started this Here is an
appeal to your president so that he
stops the simple destruction of
your citizens collect them an example of
moralization in the history of the inquisitions
Crusades and missionary work Adolf
Hitler also moralized his motivation
to create a pure Aryan race, and now
Russia is trying to prove to itself that
protecting the people of Donbas and in fact simply
invading Ukraine is its moral
duty to its alleged brothers and
sisters, of
course, even the primary analysis proves
that there is no sense in these actions, but
we still need to learn to analyze Russia
We are small l  Jews We cannot be
responsible for the actions of the authorities, this is
dissociation, a mechanism of psychological
protection. When a person does not identify himself with the
situation and tries to distance himself from it as much as possible,
in the case of
Russia, we see Russians who are
not directly in Ukraine distance themselves
from the horrors of what their compatriots
are suffering, some of them are horrified  when they understand that
with their inactive position they allowed
this to happen, that's why this protective mechanism is activated.
They say that we are
effective, why are we non-politicians?
They are so unambiguous and this is a convenient role of a
victim who refuses to take
responsibility, we
can't do anything,
and why didn't anyone say anything when  It
bombed his Slava too much,
this is a mechanism of displacement, that is,
refocusing attention from one object
to another. For example, a person was scolded at
work, but she cannot answer the
management in the same way, so she
comes home and lashes out at her
relatives, the same with Russians when they are
asked about Bucha Mariupol Kharkiv  and
other Ukrainians  which cities suffered from
war crimes in Russia, they have nothing
to answer for, but there is aggression, so they
switch their attention to other wars
someday
[music]
similar rhetoric is in tune with this ribatism,
it does not refute the original arguments,
but only disrupts the discussion of the key
issue by focusing instead on
other examples that prove
Russia's toxic attitude towards Ukraine are terribly
many, in addition to physical ones, Ukrainian
society has a number of psychological
injuries caused by Russia.
you know, you're
doing a great deal, remember it and
pass it on,
Ukraine has been resisting Russia's influence for years, and
victory in the Great War will be the
final step away from demarcation from the
aggressor country